Brian if you can answer this next
question you will win not only one but
two state-of-the-art DVD players tell us
how winning this would change your life
it would uh change it because um you
know I I'd be watching more DVDs the
question is what was George Washington's
wife's first name uh Katie Washington
I'm sorry that is incorrect shoot you
have the opportunity to win $2 million
today that's $2 million tell us how
winning that would change your life I'd
be able to pay off my student loans well
half of them at least I'd be able to pay
off my family's medical debt and get my
little brother to college basically my
life would no longer be a nightmare from
which I can never wait let's start the
challenge you have 2 seconds to do 27
back flips over this pool of lava one
two I'm so sorry you lost at least we
had fun right